JOINING US NOW, RAYMOND ARROYO,
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR OF THE WILL
WILDER SERIES.
ALL RIGHT, KEVIN HART WAS SET TO
HOST THE ACADEMY AWARDS, WHAT
HAPPENED THERE?
>> LORETTA, THE ACADEMY AND ABC
WANTED JUST WHAT THEY DID IN THE
CASE OF ROSEANNE BARR, A
LARGER-THAN-LIFE EDGY ACT THAT
WOULD DRAW A BIG AUDIENCE.
BUT WHEN CONTROVERSY FOLLOWED
THEY RAN FOR THE EXITS.
GOING BACK TO 2010, THIS IS A
BIT OF KEVIN HART’S ACT.
YOU KNEW WHAT THEY KNEW WHAT
THEY WERE GETTING INTO.
>> ONE OF MY BIGGEST FEARS IS MY
SON GROWING UP AND BEING.
IF I COULD PREVENT HIM FROM
BEING, I WILL.
EVERY KID HAS A MOMENT, BUT WHEN
IT HAPPENS, YOU HAVE TO NIP IT
IN THE BODY, STOP IT RIGHT
THERE.
>> NOW, HE ALSO WROTE SIMILAR
TWEETS AND OVER THE YEARS ABC ON
THE ACADEMY HAD TO KNOW THIS.
NOW THEY FIRED A DIRECTOR
REMEMBER A FEW YEARS BACK FOR
MAKING AN ANTI-GAY SLUR ON
TWITTER AND YOU WILL REMEMBER
WHY THEY PROBABLY HIRED KEVIN
HART, IS A BELOVED
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PERFORMER IN
THIS AGE OF OSCAR’S WHITE, AND
YOU REMEMBER HE’S SIDED WITH THE
NFL KNEELERS AND TOLD THE
PRESIDENT "TRUMP, SUCK IT."
THE ACADEMY LOVED HIM UNTIL THE
HOLLYWOOD AND THE COMMUNITY
STARTED PUSHING BACK ON
SOCIAL MEDIA CALLING HIM
HOMOPHOBIC AND ANTI, AND THEY
REACHED OUT TO HIM.
WATCH.
>> I JUST GOT A CALL FROM THE
ACADEMY AND THE CALL BASICALLY
SAID, KEVIN, I APOLOGIZE FOR
YOUR TWEET, OR WE WILL HAVE TO
MOVE ON AND FIND SOMEBODY ELSE.
SO I PASSED.
THE REASON WHY I PASSED IS
BECAUSE I HAVE ADDRESSED IT
SEVERAL TIMES.
>> HE SAID HE WOULDN’T
APOLOGIZE.
APOLOGIZE, BUT EVENTUALLY HE DID
BUT ABC WHICH IS THE NETWORK
INVOLVED IN THE ACADEMY AWARDS,
THEY DID NOT LEARN THEY OF
ROSEANNE BARR LESSON WHICH IS
WHEN THE PC DOGMA MAKES MOVES ON
YOU, STAND FIRM.
YOU CAN GET PEOPLE TO APOLOGIZE
FOR OUTRAGEOUS THINGS BUT YOU
CAN’T COLLAPSE AND THROUGH YOUR
TALENT OVERBOARD OR COMEDY, THE
LANE FOR COMEDY WILL NARROW.
GIVE PEOPLE AN OPTION.
>> Laura: WHAT DID WE PLAY
LAST NIGHT FROM JERRY SEINFELD
WHEN HE WAS ON?
>> WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE.
WATCH THIS.
COMEDY IS BY NATURE DANGEROUS.
>> AND IN THAT CLIP OF KEVIN
HART, IT SOUNDS LIKE HE IS A
SELF CHARACTER.
IT’S COMEDY.
YOU DON’T BELIEVE WHAT HE IS
SAYING, I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
WOULD SAY, THAT’S NOT -- AND I
GET IT BUT THE IDEA THAT -- OF
COURSE IT’S NOT THE WAY HE
FEELS.
>> WATCH THIS, SEINFELD.
>> I DO THIS JOKE ABOUT, PEOPLE
FEEL THEY NEED TO JUSTIFY THEIR
CELL PHONE AND I NEED TO HAVE IT
WITH ME.
WHILE THEY DON’T SEEM VERY
IMPORTANT THE WAY YOU SCROLL
THROUGH THEM LIKE A FRENCH KING.
AND THEY THOUGHT, WHAT DO YOU
MEAN?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, WHAT DO YOU
AND I THOUGHT, ARE YOU KIDDING
ME?
>> THIS IS THE PROBLEM,
EVERYBODY IS SO SENSITIVE.
WE NEED TO HAVE OUR FOIBLES SO